m
trois français enlevés à beyrouth le
djihad islamique revendique ces
enlèvements et pose ses conditions
le troisième tour des élections
cantonales ce soir l'opposition transit
vers les trois quarts des conseils
généraux français jour historique pour
les paysans européens ils manifestent
dans six pays de la communauté
européenne et demandent des prix plus
élevés
l'invité du journal et claude lelouch
pour son dernier film partir revenir qui
sort la semaine prochaine
enfin c'était ce soir la 29e journée du
championnat de france de football les
résultats en fin de journal
mesdames messieurs bonsoir 15 heures
après leur enlèvement on est toujours
sans nouvelles des trois français qui
ont été enlevés ce matin à beyrouth
il s'agit du consul adjoint de france
d'un attaché de l'ambassade de france et
de sa fille elle-même secrétaire de
l'ambassade
tout ce que l'on sait c'est que
l'organisation jihad islamique a
revendiqué l'enlèvement et qu'elle pose
maintenant ces conditions joël hasard en
échange de la libération du diplomate et
des deux fonctionnaires de l'ambassade
de france
le djihad islamique à deux exigences
annulation du contrat de vente d'avions
mirage l'arabie saoudite et fin de
l'appui apporté par paris à l'irak
contre l'iran
les conditions qui à première vue semble
désigner du doigt les intégristes chiite
libanais liés à l'iran presque les chics
n'ont pas à se plaindre de paris ils ont
apprécié l'attitude des casques bleus
français au sud liban
sans compter que la france vient de
voter en faveur d'une résolution
condamnant la répression israélienne
dans les villages chiites sullivan
le jihad islamique avait déjà revendiqué
la semaine dernière l'enlèvement de
trois occidentaux un journaliste
américain et deux ressortissants
britanniques pour l'organisation
clandestine
ces hommes étaient des agents du camp
occidental le djihad avertissait
américains britanniques de ne pas
profiter leur présence dans les régions
islamiques pour mener des opérations
subversive huit ressortissants étrangers
enlevés en un an au liban seraient aux
mains de l'organisation tous les
attentats les enlèvements revendiqués
par le djihad islamique depuis deux ans
je veux être le fait que d'un groupe
parfaitement organisé et les actions
terroristes revendiqués sont toujours
d'une précision extrême leurs
informations sans faille l'action de
services secrets plutôt de groupuscules
confessionnal manipulés de l'extérieur
c'est sur le djihad islamique ressemble
un prête-nom
si la chasse et nombre d'occidentaux du
liban ces objectifs restent obscurs
ces actions contradictoires elles se
produisent toujours à des moments
cruciaux de la crise libanaise
et puis dans le sud du liban dans la
région de saïda des cérémonies se sont
déroulées aujourd'hui à la mémoire des
victimes d'affrontements entre libanais
et israéliens parmi eux deux
journalistes de la chaîne de télévision
cbs
deux de leurs confrères français ont
assuré aujourd'hui qu'il avait été tiré
volontairement par des soldats
israéliens qui ne pouvait pas ignorer
leur identité contrairement à la thèse
avancée par tel aviv
une vingtaine d'autres personnes tuées
au cours de ratissage de plusieurs
villages ont également été inhumé en
france 3e tour des élections cantonales
les conseils généraux ont été élus
aujourd'hui où ils ont élu par dont leur
président il n'y a pas eu véritablement
de surprise l'opposition parlementaire
contrôler ce soir les trois quarts des
départements français avec hubert
coudurier voyons les départements qui
ont basculé de la gauche vers la droite
sion totalise aujourd'hui 69 présidences
de conseils généraux contre seulement 26
pour la gauche c'est dire que dix
départements basculer à droite au soir
du 17 mars quant au nouveau président 5
rpr 4d est fait un sans étiquette
leurs noms étaient dans l'ensemble
attendu dans le var maurice harek maire
de toulon succède à l'ancien maire
socialiste de draguignan edouard soldats
ni en corrèze charles ceyrac frère de
l'ancien président du cnpf remplace un
communiste élu au bénéfice de l'âge
charente maritime à aux fonctionnaires
françois blaizot succède à anne et du
socialiste tout comme dans l'oise où le
député européen jean françois mancel
obtient la présidence en gérons le
sénateur jacques valade adjoint du maire
de bordeaux relève le socialiste
philippe madrelle dans l'indre daniel
bernardet président du conseil régional
occupera la place d'andré laignel en
eure-et-loir fief radical c'est le
docteur lambour d'eau qui présidera le
conseil général surprise dans les alpes
de haute provence le sans étiquette
roger vialette élus contre le candidat
du rpr encore du sud place à josé rossi
ancien ministre vice président de
l'assemblée régionale reste un symbole
d'isère où louis mermaz s'efface devant
le maire de grenoble alain carignon deux
départements d'outre-mer ont vu en
revanche leur majorité passés de droite
à gauche en guyane
c'est un membre du parti socialiste
guyanais elie castor qui a été élu
président en guadeloupe que l'élection
du nouveau président a été reportée à
lundi faute de cordes
revenons en métropole avec le cas du
département de l'isère les yeux de tous
les observateurs politiques étaient
tournés aujourd'hui vers grenoble où se
jouait la succession du président de
l'assemblée nationale louis mermaz c'est
donc l'un des jeunes loups de
l'opposition qu'il l'a emporté un jeune
loup qui avait déjà battu à la mairie de
grenoble
un autre membre important de la gauche
hubert de bedous alain carignon n'a que
37 ans c'est rien pour une grande
première le public grenoblois s'est
pressée cet après midi dans la salle
exiguë du conseil général de l'isère
il est vrai que pour le département
l'événement ne manquait pas d'intérêt
puisque à la fiche on retrouvait les
deux acteurs principaux de la récente
campagne pour les cantonales pour la
majorité louis mermaz président de
l'assemblée nationale et président
sortant du conseil général pour
l'opposition alain carignon maire de
grenade une pièce sans suspense puisque
les dix conseillers non inscrits ont
annoncé dès hier soir qu'ils avaient
signé un accord avec l'udf et le rpr
enlevant du même coup tout espoir à
louis mermaz qui n'a donc pas jugé utile
de postuler à droite l'union à jouer à
100% puisque tous sont tombés d'accord
sur une seule candidature celle d'alain
carignon calanques fait le plein des
voix udf rpr et non inscrits soit 30 de
bulletins sur 57 majorité absolue dès le
premier tour
nous célébrons aujourd'hui le succès
d'un département et non pas le succès de
partis politiques
et je tiens ici à le souligner de
nombreux travaux nous attend et défis
considérables sont là nous devons les
relever ensemble nous devrons et nous
devons servir lisait dans mes collègues
et moi même continuer à travailler très
activement pour ce département et je
veillerai notamment en ce qui me
concerne à ce que le volume de grands
travaux que nous avons fait venir ici ce
département particulièrement dynamique
soit maintenue nous sommes nous restons
au service bien entendu de l'ensemble de
la population de l'isère
ce soir le conseil municipal de grenoble
réuni en séance extraordinaire a clamé
le nouveau chef du conseil général de
l'isère
la première fois dans l'histoire
politique locale que le premier
magistrat de la capitale devient numéro
un du département alain carignon à
effectuer jusqu'à ce jour un parcours
sans faute mais lorsque le challenger se
transforme en leader c'est lui la cible
privilégiée est ici comme ailleurs il
lui faudra désormais davantage penser à
tenir qu'à courir pour georges marchais
le choix de la loi électorale est
quelque chose de vital
il a dit aujourd'hui en ajoutant qu'il
combattra une fausse proportionnelle
visant plus à consolider le pouvoir
socialiste qu'à permettre une meilleure
représentation des forces politiques
fin de citation palabres en nouvelle
calédonie 70 jours après la mort des
lois macherot edgard pisani est allé at
you ce matin rendre visite à la tribu de
l'ancien leader kanak une visite pas du
tout évidente puisque elle lui avait été
refusé il y à un mois
cette fois ci et pour la première fois
le délégué du gouvernement français a pu
discuter avec des militants de base du
fln ks et à l'occasion de cette
réconciliation et au cours des
conversations
edgar pisani a déclaré qu'il assumait
seule la responsabilité d'opérations au
cours de laquelle eloi macherot avaient
trouvé la mort
il est mort en combattant et comme tel
il mérite respect je le salue comme tel
c'est sous ma responsabilité que c'est
engager l'opération
oui il est mort j'en assume seul la
responsabilité
nous n'avions pas l'intention s'il meurt
nous avions l'intention d'arrêter
l'aventuré dans laquelle il s'était
lancé
je m'incline devant sa dépouille le rpr
a immédiatement protesté contre cette
déclaration selon lui cela confirme que
le gouvernement s'obstine à traiter avec
ceux qui se comportent en ennemis de la
france et de la république
sow 22 mars 1985 restera sans doute une
date historique pour les paysans
européens pour la première fois en effet
les agriculteurs de six pays de la
communauté européenne ont manifesté en
même temps et pour les mêmes raisons des
hausses de prix qu'il juge insuffisante
un élargissement du marché commun qui
leur fait peur pour les responsables de
ces manifestations
il s'agit d'un avertissement claude
guaino la capitale de l'europe a été le
temps fort de cette journée de
protestation
quatre mille agriculteurs ouest allemand
franchi le pont de kehl pour se joindre
aux 7000 manifestants français à trois
jours du marathon de bruxelles où les
dix doit fixer les prix agricoles pour
85 c'est l'union sacrée du monde paysan
européen pour défendre son revenu
celui ci ne cesse de baisser depuis dix
ans dit la fnsea qui réclame une
augmentation de 5% alors que bruxelles
propose un gel des prix ou la ronde
il m'arrive à moi tu es loin là où tout
le monde est au premier est homologué
le lendemain aujourd'hui c'est un
premier avertissement ont bien reçu quel
cinéma
ils vont être plus nombreux pour
défendre nos intérêts et notre activité
et leur avis nous le saurons tout son
sens pour sauver la vie dure et l'homme
cent cinquante mille agriculteurs ont
manifesté aujourd'hui dans toute la
france selon françois guillaume dans le
midi pour la première fois les
viticulteurs se sont ralliés à la fnsea
leur principal motif d'inquiétude
l'élargissement du marché commun en
normandie on à protester contre les
quotas laitiers et accueilli une
délégation de fermier britannique dans
le nord comme un peu partout dans le
pays
il y a eu des barrages sur les grands
axes routiers toutes ces manifestations
se sont déroulées dans le calme sauf à
poitiers où il ya eu quelques incidents
dans la soirée
coup de théâtre à bruxelles hier on
croyait bien que les dix allaient enfin
arrivés à un accord sur l'entrée de
l'espagne et du portugal dans le marché
commun hélas la nuit dernière les
négociations ont encore échoué avec
toujours trois dossiers à régler
pierre-yves callies aux 300 bateaux
espagnols dont la moitié autorisés à
pêcher simultanément dans les eaux
communautaires c'était le chiffre sur
lequel après bien des tractations les
dix sont des s'être mis d'accord pas la
france apparemment qui veut ramener ces
chiffres à deux cent cinquante et cent
trente de même roland dumas estime qu'il
serait souhaitable de pêcher un peu plus
en mer du nord et un peu moins dans le
golfe de gascogne
ajoutons à cela la volonté du portugal
de protéger son secteur pêche pendant
dix ans face à l'armada espagnole
côté fruits et légumes les produits
espagnols font peur aux producteurs
français résultats mésentente sur le
démantèlement des droits de douane
durant les quatre premières années pour
la distillation obligatoire à bas prix
des vins de table espagnole
la france souhaite un plafond de 25
millions d'hectolitres l'espagne 32
la présidence italienne a proposé un
compromis à 28
sans doute une solution possible
personne ne niant le problème des vins
du midi
en tout cas rendez vous jeudi prochain
cinéma avec son dernier film partir
revenir on peut dire que claude lelouch
est un véritable tournant de sa carrière
il s'agit d'un film qui se passe sous
l'occupation et dans lequel lellouche a
osé aborder un problème à la fois très
actuelle est très difficile celui de la
réincarnation
nous allons retrouver claude lelouch
dans quelques secondes en compagnie
d'henri chapier mais avant je vous
invite à voir un court extrait de ce
film où se mêlent humour et métaphysique
en on savait que sa fille est une
chapelle de 11e siècle
si on pouvait visiter et d'ailleurs les
doigts
depuis le cake la durée avec deux
transformations qui y vivent bien sûr
cela je peux prédire et comment elles
fabriquent le pont la petite porte là
bas une partie de ces châteaux
d'ailleurs qui sait sur quoi la sexy et
les ondes
en peu visible et s'il vous plaît
où
alors oui chapier vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous aviez beaucoup ce film
est ce le thème de la réincarnation qui
vous excite tant que ça non je crois que
c'est pas le seul je pense que là il
s'agit d'un très très grand film de
claude lelouch et s'est divisé de le
résumer en une minute on est extrêmement
ému parce que pour la première fois on a
fait un cinéma qui vous donnent des
joies que vous donne d'habitude la
littérature la peinture la musique c'est
pas seulement parce qu'un concerto de
rachmaninov
c'est là je crois qu'il a réussi quelque
chose d'extrêmement rare il y à austin
histoire bien sûr et il y a quelque
chose de très optimiste dans la
générosité de ce film à savoir que nous
sommes peut-être immortel pas nous vous
moi mais nous la race humaine et ceux
qui ont plus de génie que d'autres
peut-être aussi alors avec le déluge
êtes-vous satisfait parce description de
votre film qui vient des fêtes
oui ça me plaît c'est ça me plaît c'est
enfin je veux dire qu'il ya plein de
thèmes qui se chevauchent à l'intérieur
ce film n'a pas simplement la
réincarnation et à l'occupation qui joue
un rôle important je crois qu'il faut
pas passer sur cet événement qui restera
sûrement le plus grand événement de tous
les temps que qu'est la deuxième guerre
mondiale et je crois que nous sommes
tous des enfants de ce deuxième guerre
mondiale et que si aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une société plus tolérante
72 l'axé partie il y à la délation qui
joue un très grand rôle
les statines sur la passion c'est un
film sur la passion cette passion qui
nous donne à tous l'énergie de faire
l'impossible qui vous donne la force de
nous lever tous les matins et de faire
ce que j'appelle des miracles alors donc
tous ces thèmes se chevauchent
j'ai essayé de les construire un petit
peu à l'intérieur d'un polar d'un polar
d'un opéra polar je sais pas où polar
opéra enfin je sais pas comment les gens
vont prendre ce film mais c'est vrai que
j'ai voulu montrer encore une fois à
quel point l'être humain était
terriblement fragile et terriblement
solide à quel point cette invention ne
pouvait pas mourir qu'une telle
invention ne pouvait pas finir par le
mot mort c'est vrai que je crois quelque
part je crois pas la régression personne
ne peut croire la réincarnation mais à
force d'observation je dire à un moment
donné on est bien obligé de prendre une
décision sur toutes les solutions qu'on
nous propose c'est vrai que je crois
qu'il y a des vies où on apprend il ya
des vies où on vit et je crois que ceux
qui réussissent le mieux sont ceux qui
ont un peu plus de mémoire d'une vie sur
l'autre et c'est un petit peu le cas
d'un des personnages de ce film qui de
vie en vie s'améliore jusqu'à devenir
dans les années 85 un grand pianiste un
grand pianiste qui a terriblement
souffert dans sa vie précédente et qui
justement sa souffrance et le résultat
son interprétation d'aujourd'hui alors
le film évidemment couvre une période
très longue qui va de 1920 à 1985 qui
ont veillé à un petit côté saga mais il
fallait cette durée il fallait ces
soixante années pour essayer de tenter
d'expliquer comment le talent venait à
certains et
et comment les choses mûrissent fille il
faut je crois que les gens sont
peut-être légaux sur plusieurs vies
alors que à l'intérieur d'une même ville
ya beaucoup de justice mais cycle de
jauge fait en tout cas on retiendra
surtout que c'est aussi un hymne d'amour
merci claude lelouch il joue aussi bien
du classique que du jazz il vient de
recevoir le césar pour la musique du
film les cavaliers de l'orage
il a été surnommé le paganini de la
clarinette son nom michel portal michel
portal et ce soir et encore demain au
théâtre de la ville de paris voici
quelques aspects de son talent présenté
par jean-louis magallon l'homme à la
clarinette s'appelle michel portal
aujourd'hui il joue mozart avec quatre
heures à gaine de salzbourg
hier ou avant-hier c'était schomberg
berio demain avec d'autres musiciens de
jazz comme un percussionniste antilla
mino cinelu tout juste arrivé des
etats-unis
il ira s'aventurer sur les terres
inconnues de nouvelles d'improvisation
avec la même passion folle de la musique
de toutes les musiques - moushin
bruxelles entend dans le jeu et dans le
classique jégou delà de l'écriture ça je
suis très respectueux mais moi je marche
surtout par les temps libre je suis
quelqu'un qui tangente dans les teintes
comme tout à l'heure moi ça ça me donne
des idées musicales
je suis pas quelqu'un qui composa une
table comme ça en disant tu aussi phare
et diez ne sais pas je peux pas jouer
mozart dans deux heures et non maître à
jouer avec mino maintenant malgré qu'ils
aient ce qu'ils viennent faire là ça m'a
complètement c'est pas mal je voudrais
qu'il faudrait qu'ils disent car même
devons parce que j'ai revu minon avec
miles davis et weezer report il ya
quelques temps et je voudrais qu'il
parle un petit peu de ses impressions
il ya quand même une cohésion et les
gens se respectent et n'oublie pas que
c'est quand même la musique de michel
conques on interprète principalement
c'est ça bon ils n'y seraient pas
ouverts il m'a dit tu peux apporter des
morceaux et cetera mais enfin c'est
quand même la cancer de michel et tout
le monde doit garder ça dans son esprit
quoi qu'il fasse même si je fais un saut
lors de trois heures et demie je le
ferai en respectant le fait que son
cancer sont des sortes de rencontres ou
de métissage peu de musique
football c'était ce soir la 29e journée
du championnat de france les matchs
viennent tout juste de se terminer
dominique champeau des surprises oui des
surprises non n'a pas su profiter ce
soir de l'absence de bordeaux dans cette
9e journée vous savez que bordeaux après
son match de coupe d'europe à 24 heures
pour se remettre de ses émotions
on sait depuis aujourd'hui qu'il
affrontera la juventus de turin demi
finales des coupes d'europe champions le
10 et 24 avril prochain donc 29e journée
sans cette équipe de bordeaux et nous
sommes attachés ce soir au progrès d'une
équipe monégasque qui est invaincu
maintenant depuis la mi-décembre qui
recevrait marseille et qui en première
mi-temps va multiplier les occasions ici
à l'image d'amoros se heurtant à chaque
fois sur le gardien les vies de
nombreuses occasions monégasques mais
aucun but marqué en cette première mi
temps et ce n'est pas ces centres de
beloeil qui va permettre aux monégasques
de pouvoir enfin trouvé le chemin des
filets de lévis les marseillais
réagissent en armement la ligne étant le
plus roulement est tout de suite en fin
de première mi-temps dernier vous de la
traversée à l'ocs sera mais les casques
avec un superbe tir de l'euro mais 0 à 0
rien n'était marqué la deuxième mi temps
allait être beaucoup plus fertile en bus
avec notamment deux actions superbe de
bruno bellone voici la première attirant
play le putsch du pied gauche 1 0
et une remarquable action quelques
minutes après d'ellen va se jouer des
deux défenseurs marseillais
une première fois petit crochet un
deuxième prochaine val contrer un tir
brossé du pied gauche qui permet à
monaco d'envisager la victoire 2 à 0 en
fin de partie sur ce corner de wendel
c'est benoît sur ce mauvais renvoi de la
défense marseillaise qui permet de la
rue de la ferté largement 3 à 0 monaco
se replace dans la course pour une coupe
d'europe vous le voyez nantes a été tenu
en échec sur son terrain par sochaux
les nantais ont marqué sur penalty
pendant les arrêts de jeu toulon tenu en
échec lui aussi à domicile large
victoire de monaco on l'a vu paris saint
germain battu à domicile par m belle
victoire de brest devant lens pour les
mal classés le racing de paris a été
battu à lille tours tenu en échec à
bastia c'est un résultat honorable
strasbourg également l'échec à nancy et
laval le même score à tous
et puis un mode rugby le rugby qui va
avoir son championnat du monde
l'international board en a décidé ainsi
aujourd'hui même à paris première
édition dans deux ans en mai 87 en
australie et en nouvelle-zélande il y
aura un tiercé demain à saint cloud qui
se disputera dans le prix de la cour
voici les pronostics de monsieur
courtine le 1 c'est le joker voilà
puis le 8 le 12 le neuf le 5 le 10 et le
dé nouveau plongeon du dollar
aujourd'hui à paris la monnaie
américaine a perdu 17 centimes
une explication l'économie des états
unis pourrait connaître une croissance
moins forte que prévu henry lauret dans
le droit fil de la forte baisse
enregistrée hier soir à new york le
dollar aujourd'hui en europe a fortement
reculé partout et notamment bien sûr à
paris où il a clôturé à près de 9 francs
la bourse de paris elle n'a cure des
remous monétaire du moins les
apprécie-t-elle à sa manière et cela
donne une hausse de 1% mais oui pour un
pour cent pour le nouveau mois boursiers
à wall street en fin on s'interroge pour
la volt street une expansion ralenti
c'est à la fois bon et mauvais pour la
bourse
il serait peut-être préférable
d'attendre les résultats définitifs pour
se déterminer
60 centimes de baisse dans la même
semaine c'est énorme le dollar a plongé
une telle vitesse que l'on a pu croire à
un moment donné à une débandade sur les
marchés monétaires aujourd'hui à paris
vous l'avez entendu il a encore reculé
de 5 centimes pour expliquer cette
dégringolade ya d'abord eu cette fameuse
histoire des petites banques de dépôt
dans l'ohio
et puis surtout il ya eu ces chiffres de
la croissance américaine des chiffres
très ralentie 2,1 pour cent alors comme
anticipé des chiffres de l'ordre de 4%
alors on peut concevoir en réalité que
les chiffres de la croissance qu'il est
une estimation a servi de détonateur
pour un réajustement sur le marché
nombreux sont ceux qui pensent en effet
qu'on était allé trop loin avec un
dollar à près de trois mares 40 promark
50 et qu'une parité de 3,18 3,25 et est
plus conforme à la réalité
cela donne pour nous français aux
alentours de 9 francs 80 ont nié
aujourd'hui on ne peut donc pas parler
encore de psycho sur le dollar mais on
peut dire qu'il ya un réflexe de
méfiance et il sera intéressant attendre
lundi pour savoir si les marchés se sont
stabilisés ou non il est temps de voir
ce que nous réserve le ciel demain dans
l'ensemble la france sera divisé en 3 du
nord de la bretagne en passant par
l'ile-de-france le ciel sera très
nuageux avec des pluies parfois mêlées
de neige
d'autant et même soleil en alsace et sur
les côtes de la méditerranée
partout ailleurs temps instable avec
éclaircies et averses
les températures varieront entre 4
degrés à lille rennes et paris et 7
degrés à ajaccio voilà les températures
qui s'inscrivent sur votre écran donc
entre 4 et 7 de fin de ce journal dans
quelques instants vous avez rendez vous
avec georgette lemaire et laisser passer
la chanson demain nous nous retrouverons
à 21h55
en attendant voici le rappel des titres
que nous avons développé ce soir très
bonne soirée sur fr3 en français enlevé
à beyrouth le djihad islamique
revendique ces enlèvements et pose ses
conditions
3e tour des élections cantonales
l'opposition président les trois quarts
des conseils généraux français les
paysans de six pays européens dans la
rue c'est un avertissement aux
négociateurs de bruxelles football
championnat de france nantes tenu en
échec à domicile par sochaux
ah ah